you have this opinion which is known as
case law here in Canada
which is a story about a guy that met a
gal online on a dating app took her out
on a date and
tldr version of it is he's now going to
prison or or he's facing uh jail time
for what happened so can you walk the
audience through this
um story and what the cautionary tale is
with that before we get into you know
family law and divorce law and what's
happening you know in the future yeah
absolutely thank you Rich for the
introduction uh basically uh there was a
case in Pennsylvania unpublished opinion
that came out in Pennsylvania Superior
Court December 30th 2022. uh
Commonwealth versus Wilton and uh you
could just Google Pennsylvania Superior
Court or maybe ritual put it the link in
the show notes long story short a guy
goes on a dating app and um he matches
with a woman and they decide to meet at
a bar a restaurant bar and they're
talking to each other for a couple hours
they're kissing each other they're
talking about very intimate uh Jacks
what kind of intimacy they like
she's showing him pictures of her most
private areas on her cell phone
and after about a couple of hours of
hanging out at the bar she invites him
into her SUV where uh he pulls down his
his pants and uh the rest is that he
said she said
uh the cautionary tale here is she
claims that he assaulted her and that he
uh somehow forced her to
perform sex acts on them or do things
that she didn't agree to had he his side
of the story is different than hers
uh so it's a real cautionary tale that
you better be very careful if uh you're
a man out there especially if you don't
have a lot of experience and you don't
know the other person so this guy goes
out on maybe a Tinder date I don't know
what the dating app was it doesn't say
in the opinion and the next thing you
know he's charged with multiple sex
crimes he gets convicted and
he loses his appeal so he'll be in state
prison for at least two and a half years
his sentence was two and a half to five
years then he has five years of
probation after that what do you think
the motivation was
like why would she do something like
this uh you never know what what she may
have uh tried to extort money from him
and say look if you don't pay me she was
convicted of uh welfare fraud years
before so they were able to get that
conviction and evidence as a criminal
falsy crime she was uh not honest and
she was convicted of being dishonest and
he still got convicted so just a word to
the wise if you're a guy out there
be very very careful you know he invited
her to a hotel room and she declined
that should have been his first sign
that you know she's not into this right
now and she's not into him uh and then
why would she invite him into her SUV uh
like why did he follow her in there and
there's a lot of unanswered questions
but the problem I have with it is
um he probably should have thought this
through a little more closely before
getting undressed in her car or pulling
his pants down which is what was in the
opinion that he did so I just wanted to
bring up The Upfront to uh your audience
bring it to their attention because yeah
so I want to ask you a couple questions
around this because I mean there's a lot
of like characters in The Mano swamp
that sell like pick up Artistry courses
and one of the angles that they tend to
use is is an acronym SNL which stands
for same night lay so clearly this guy
was making advances on this gal
um but she reciprocated she's she's
egging them on showing him pictures of
her nude body she invites him into the
SUV
um and then it kind of escalated from
there and then she obviously had buyer's
remorse the next day and then
you know bad man over there made me do
bad things I want you know legal help
you know help me help me help me please
right um do you have any do you have any
advice for guys on maybe spotting these
Sirens you know these these crazies that
might potentially complicate a guy's
life I mean does it like I mean I'm sure
he didn't Google her first and last name
plus welfare fraud uh you know plus case
law in the state to see if anything
would come up most guys wouldn't think
about that but is there any like
is there any advice that you might have
for guys to sort of screen out these
Nutters
uh first piece of advice and I gave this
to uh let me just preface this I'm not
your lawyer if you're watching this it's
not quote legal advice but I would say
this uh be very careful first of all if
uh anyone's intoxicated because then
they can't give you consent like if
they're passed out so if he was plowing
her with drinks or I told the high
school kids years ago when I used to
talk to them
if someone's passed out make sure
they're okay you know get them help make
sure they're not uh you know
over the limit where they could be in
danger in serious danger but don't do
anything with them that's terrible
you're going to get yourself into a ton
of trouble at at what point does the
legal system consider somebody
intoxicated generally where they
wouldn't be able to make a rational
choice about inviting a guy into their
SUV and then inviting a guy to take off
his pants and then escalating it from
there like
Where's the Line in the Sand where it's
like oh well she was kind of drooling in
half asleep so she was clearly you know
intoxicated versus well she was clearly
walking nice and straight in a straight
line from the bar to the car and had one
drink like how do you distinguish that
yeah I was a guy I would clearly if it
were me I would be on the clear side era
on the side of caution and you want him
to be sober you don't want some you want
a woman to show genuine burning desire
for you or nothing or forget it like if
she said you know what uh let's take a
shower together let's take a bath
together uh you know she's completely
sober hasn't been drinking there's no
signs of intoxication you want her to
have all of her wits about her uh you
don't want her in that even in that gray
area why be
put yourself in that position I wouldn't
uh
I don't care how thirsty you are don't
do it do it's not worth it because cases
like this come about it becomes a he
said she said make sure consent is clear
and they are of clear sound mind don't
take a chance where somebody can come
back later and said I was intoxicated or
I passed out or you don't want to deal
with that kind of stuff have you seen
anything as far as opinions or maybe
case law that makes any recommendations
as far as guys you know protecting
themselves or like what can guys get
away with so I've heard stories of guys
using things like nanny cams in their
house to record consent without them
actually you know knowing that they're
being recorded like where does the law
stand on something like that because you
know if she if she turns around the next
day and says well you know he graped me
and I didn't consent and this is
completely offside and I didn't want
this to happen but he has video evidence
of her initiating the entire process
like how does the law look at something
like that is that something that guys
can use to protect themselves not really
you got to be careful because in some
jurisdictions it's illegal to record
somebody unless both parties know
they're being recorded in other
jurisdictions just one party so you
gotta it can change from jurisdiction to
jurisdiction you would need somebody's
permission and so you don't want to find
yourself on the wrong side of the law
depending upon what the law is uh there
are guys who have hidden cameras and
nanny cameras hidden in stuffed animals
or hidden in a closet somewhere with a
hole in the wall you better not do that
if you're not allowed to in your
jurisdiction you'll get in a heap of
trouble so there's no easy answer I
would say really vet the person very
carefully this same night lay or
whatever the uh whatever the acronym was
you're you're asking for it you really
need to be careful yeah I've said to
guys many times I'm like you know use
your first date as a sniff test have a
drink you know do you know just take an
hour out of your day have a drink go for
a walk grab a coffee sort of thing sniff
her out see what she's all about
um but if you're gonna follow the advice
of some of these you know nefarious
Cuckoos that are telling you to like
roll around with every chick you
possibly can within 20 minutes of
meeting them you're eventually going to
smash into something like this which is
going to cause problems for you I mean
a woman of higher character
isn't going to be showing you nude
pictures of herself in a bar
a woman of higher character is not going
to invite you in a car and invite you to
take off your clothes uh that early on I
mean it can wait like why can't it wait
you know for you to have like a second
or third date and say Hey you know come
over to my place let's go over to your
place sort of thing you can make things
happen there and then if you want at
least you have a little more time to
sort of size her up to see what she's
made of
but I don't think guys are are giving
themselves enough time just and just
rushing into this headstrong it seems
like it's a problem is this the first
time you've seen this or is this pop up
a lot for you uh I've seen a couple of
other times and I hate these to see
these cases where it becomes down to it
he said she said because it's always
whatever she said goes now right well
he's he said uh she touched his uh
genitals and she said no he forced me
onto his generals as he was sitting in
passenger seat of the car you know to
convict somebody of that and there's
such a diverse uh rendition of what
happened I wasn't at the trial but she
could you know she had a lot of other
emotional issues she sobbed during the
trial which uh was another problem for
his case because uh there was a problem
with the jury instructions around that
I'm thinking to myself man and if you
just used a little bit more common sense
and were a little more Discerning around
how you went about this I didn't know
how old the guy was but he had to be the
age of majority to be tried in an adult
Court not as a juvenile so let's say he
was in his 20s or 30s
um are you really that thirsty to have
someone that you don't know you know
have a you know a sexual encounter with
you in a car I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out